là et tout ce qui lui est attachée comme
si elle n'existait pas ce qui me
permettrait de supprimer toutes ces
créatures d'attaqué comme un bourrin et
du coup de gueule un peu patraque et ça
c'est pas mal comme scénario donc du
coup je rajoute s'est dit que c'était là
je pioche une carte là les gens voient
ce que c'est comme ça que j'ai quand
même rigolé là j'ai droit de parler de
la variance quand même un petit peu
ah bah ça les bons mais après tout ok
donc là le vélo à narguilé que j'ai
pioché une carte qui ne m'intéressait
pas mais comme j'ai pioché une carte
attends je suis bête je joue on fait la
chaîne seconde carte ça avant comme ça
je pioche ma seconde carte qui est l île
et du coup je le remets un marqueur aux
deux est ce que est ce que mariana élite
autorise à revenir en arrière parce que
tu as déjà pas mal de revenir en arrière
ou par dessus sinon je les ai trouvés
donc tu as un deux trois quatre
créatures
ll on le vole comme j'ai pioché d'autres
trucs lui je peux encore tenté de le
sacrifier
ouais je peux faire ça être un peu
d'ordre au delà
commencent à arriver sur un terrain peu
compliqué ouais ouais mais cela dit moi
j'aime bien quand les trucs qui se clean
au fur et à mesure tu vois donc là j'ai
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 assez d'argent de la
situation - des c'est plus pratique
gueule d'un petit 4 13 14
non mais en fait j'ai 14 avec des
créatures qui volent c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour toi marie magnet ouais bah
du coup j'attaque avec toutes les
créatures qui vole je te fais 14 dégâts
et un étant donné que la dernière carte
sim rester estiment que là bas je peux
te dire qu'il me restait quatre îles en
main c'est un des traits là que j'étais
cela dit si tu avais cela dit c'est
marie amélie comme dernière qu'intel
avait une carte qui détruisait une
créature avec le vol jeudi et bien on
peut aller dedans ouais elle me contre
est derrière et si j'avais été patient
au tour d'après du coup j'avais assez
pour activer le plein le coeur et les
faire le sauter la phase d des créatures
de marie amélie est ce que tu pouvais
leur identité tu peux dire pourquoi tu
fais choisir des cartes à charles tout à
l'heure oui alors donc comme on disait
tout à l'heure il ya un concept de
saison donc une des raisons pour
lesquelles la pratique des égards josy
ce cet attrait pour les joueurs c'est
qu'ils renouvellent les cartes sans
cesse il crée sans cesse des nouvelles
cartes et d'autres choses et notamment
celles dont qu'elle est thématique
annuelle 2020-2021 etc
il ya des saisons avec des thématiques
dont notamment la saison des gros
monstres
donc ça explique nous quelle est cette
saison des gros monstres et ensuite on
va parler des cartes une par une pendant
que je mélange ça et dites-nous en 4 si
vous voulez que je change de dec pour un
noir à la place je vois peut la
retourner je me demande si on a encore
le temps de jeu et j'ai peur de perdre
ok je vais savourer sur un savoir voilà
score auquel est neutre et bien
ça le côté suisse est normalement vous
devez vous traque à l'écran les cartes
une par une choisi par charles et vas-y
charles à toi le micro ok donc du coup
il ya des éditions qui sortent à peu
près toutes les trois hommes tous les
trois mois qui se passe sur différents
plans donc c'est des univers à eux qui
ont leur propre géographie et c'est
qu'ils sont pas connectés les uns aux
autres et à travers desquels les plus
hauts le coeur peuvent voyager et dans
le cas présent le plus récent qui a été
utilisée c'est le monde dit coriat qui
était donc un monde où il ya plein de
d'énormes monstres et qui a joué un peu
en mode en mode godzilla d'ailleurs ils
ont fait une une opération spéciale avec
godzilla passé ils sont partenaires et
du coup il y avait énormément de gros
bestiaux sur ce monstre là et en fait
c'est le monde d'origine de viviane qui
est donc le plein au sol qu'un verre
qu'on a vu dans le bec de marie-amélie
tout à l'heure je crois que c'était une
passion oui ça
voilà qui vient de ce monde et lui
coûter une archère voilà qui contrôlent
des trucs tu vas sortir à l'écran voilà
et donc il ya un monde que je trouvais
assez cool parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
créatures avec des effets intéressants
et pas seulement des grosses bêtes avec
des grosses tâches qu'on pouvait
imaginer parce que bon les discours des
série golo mais pas forcément un truc
qu'on recherche
tu vois quoi on fait des choses
intéressantes est ce que j'aime beaucoup
avec magix et que leurs bombes sont
quand même assez différent même si
parfois ils sont inspirés de deux
différentes mythologies faire que voilà
celui ci c'était 1-1 monde voilà autour
des abeilles mortes et des gros monstres
mais il ya d'autres univers qui sont par
exemple autour des vampires ou des loups
garous un peu à l'acte hulu il ya deux
univers qui sont plus autour des pirates
les dinosaures genre de choses
bref boussaha eros ça change un peu aux
hétéros c'était autour de la mythologie
grecque par exemple et avoir un mode
quête il y avait vu la mythologie
égyptienne et et voilà donc le monde
avec les pirates et les dinosaures
c'était des arrivées des ondes en aussi
ça pxl lan et apparemment ça ses
références à des mythologies un car et
c'est un truc que je connais pas très
bien mais du coup ça sympa parce que
l'univers graphique se renouvelle en
blouse d'avoir les mécaniques
changes et du cou régulièrement on
essaie des choses nouvelles et donc le
choix des cartes pour alors dans le cas
présent celle qu'on a un écran là c'est
le le typhon de requin est une carte qui
me plaît beaucoup parce que à la fois
elle est très cool et en plus elle est
très forte
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est cool c'est
un clin d'oeil évident au film cherche
nadeau voilà c'est c'est une tornade
dans lequel il ya des requins qui vole
je trouve ça déjà très drôle de base et
du coup l'idée c'est que c'est une carte
qui créent des requins volant est en
fait la façon dont elle fonctionne à
vous faire un peu gaffe parce que là
l'overlay cache un peu le taxent de la
carte s'écarte un peu compliqué donc à
tous le tec dessus des gens peuvent pas
trop le voir mais en gros c'est ça une
carte cadeau mode ça il ya un mode où on
la joue normalement c'est un
enchantement qui coûte cher at il dit à
chaque fois que vous lancez un sort dans
créatures donc comme dans le dans le
dec2 valentin y avait beaucoup de sorman
créatures qui est épluché des cartes par
exemple vous pouvez créer un jeton de
créatures requins avec le vol dont la
force et l'endurance mégalomane à du
sort que vous venez de jouer donc si
vous jouez un sort qui coûte deux à vous
créer une de 2 volts sortie coût de 3
vous créez une 3 3 vols etc
en gros c'est intéressant parce que ça
vous créer des créatures à partir de
sorts qui vous permettront d'attaquer de
bloquer guy la partie de saison le losc
à ces pratiques et un deuxième mode
qu'elle recyclage avec un coup modulaire
qu'il ya des x partout dans le texte
donc il n'est pas forcément évident ça
coûte ex1 incolore et un bleu ya
toujours le le relais irola il
exactement sur le texte mon cas je parle
pour les gens forcément évident mais
après si vous cherchez la carte vous
verrez plus facilement et en gros l'idée
c'est que la bécane de recyclage c'est
une mécanique qui vous permet de
remplacer la carte que vous avez en main
par une autre
la d 60 puis en piochant encore et donc
ça c'est utile par exemple lorsque fois
vous avez des cartes très cher que du
coup si vous pouvez pas les jouets vous
avez envie de les recycler pour trouver
les terrains gouvernement vous avez
terrain qu'on le recyclage et vous
pouvez les défauts c'est pour trouver
d'autres cartes et celle-ci en fait
lorsque vous la défausse et vous payer
autant que vous voulez et ça vous fait
1-1 un vin un requin volant xx donc x
étant la valeur que vous avez payé moins
deux concerts que si vous payez 2 vous
n'avez pas votre token et 0 0 mais à
partir de plus que 2 donc si vous payez
5 par exemple la veine 33 vols et en
plus vous payez une carte donc ce qu'est
ce qui est vraiment chouette avec cette
carte c'est qu'elle est toujours bien et
en plus elle a ce côté contre intuitif
que le deuxième mode qu'est le mode de
recyclage
c'est le mode qu'on utilisera le plus
souvent par rapport au premier mode et
c'est une carte qui à la fois bien
équilibrée et cool en termes de design
et du coup j'aime beaucoup
voilà pour toutes ces raisons là
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est avait
cette carte là on entendait que valentin
il serait pas mal plus fort oui
effectivement bas on va voir il me reste
un ou deux boosters correia jeu je vais
croiser les doigts pour ses avoirs et
lyon sais tu que si tu peux l'avouer si
je peux être un peu désagréable et de
redemander à ce qu'on enlève le relais
figaro live juste le temps qu'on
explique les cartes parce que ouais
merci beaucoup pour les textes et plus
pratique
le deuxième dont j'ai parlé sécher ville
fléau des monstres donc lui tient un
humain il est vert et noir qui fout mal
un verre et un manager pour le jouer
c'est une 1,3 contact mortel qui est
humain gredins et déjà il ya beaucoup de
classe je trouve sur l'image d'un petit
côté tiger king sais pas si vous avez vu
la syrie avec sa grosse moustache est
enrôlé d'excelsyn c'est une 1,3 contact
mortels et au début de notre entretien
si votre adversaire n'a pas de deux
permanents avec une changer de carte là
c'est pas grave à repasser dessus s'il
est pas à faire à travers ça n'a pas de
permanents avec un un marqueur prime
dessus vous pouvez mettre un marqueur
prime sur une créature ont appelé soit
le coeur est en gros du coup ça va être
vous mettez une prime comme un chasseur
de primes il ya la mettre sur une
créature on appelle cela le coeur est
donc temps qu'un oeil vous fait rien et
quand il y en a plus vous avez choper la
prime à vous en remettez sur un truc
nouveau
et lorsque vous vous détruisez le
permanent qui a une prime de suaux gagné
trois points de vie vous pêchez une
carte et du coup je trouve qu'on a pas
mal on a bien saisi l'idée du chasseur
de primes avec ça sa grosse épée qui va
dégommer tous les gros monstre un par un
et attend qu'il n'a pas trop étant qu'il
a pas réussi à battre son gros mumbai à
s'acharner dessus un peu comme le
méchant dans tout mangé sa chambre sur
le gars je trouvais ça c'est un peu le
même des liens et en plus c'est une
carte qui est assez sympa donc voila moi
je trouve qu'elle parlait bien celle ci
j'ai une carte qui a ses formes de
manière générale en plus d'être d'être
assez cool et la troisième c'est
l'artisan fielleux donc luce et là c'est
la plus compliquée les trois mais elle
est aussi très sympa donc déjà dans le
matin vous allez voir que le son coût de
mana il est spécifique cdma la hybride
vert ou noir
donc voila vous la jouer dans un acte
qui cauberg on a quelques noirs avec
elle et deux en général c'est plus
facile à jouer sur des quais noir bleu
ou vert blanc n'importe quoi et en gros
en fait ces nains mais gagne plus un peu
un pour chaque arbre de créatures dans
votre sim card
si vous jouez un des kebabs à
l'orientation le signal il peut être
très gros déjà pas seulement pour 2 vous
pouvez avoir une 5,5 par exemple et moi
ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est sa capacité
active et donc c'est une capacité que
vous pouvez me lancer que le que lorsque
vous lancerez un rituel ses marques et
tout en bas
la cobas tessin peu contrainte 8e mais
ce marché comme ça du coup vous faire
gaffe parce que ben c'est comme
l'équipement de de l'artefact de tout à
l'heure tu voulais qu'il vend le tour ça
marche pas tu dois faire que à ton tour
c'est ça au moment où tu pourrais jouer
une créature par exemple et du kangourou
tu payes x + 1 qui est un vert ou noir
tu langage et l'aptitude le symbole de
la petite flèche ça veut dire qu'il faut
que tu engages sa créature
donc du coup tu peux pas le faire au
premier tour parce qu'elle est mal
d'invocation faudra attendre un tour et
du coup tu une fois que la fête je peux
plus apte à kiev
mais du coup tu te fais sacrifier notre
créature est caché dans son bec une
carte qui coûte xxl c'est le coup que tu
as payé en mana et que la messe
directement sur le champ de bataille et
du coup ça c'est super cool parce qu'en
fait ça te permettre de construire ton
bec différemment avec certaines cartes
qu'on appellera des belettes c'est à
dire des cartes qui sont des silver
bullet en fait qu'on utilise pour tuer
un vampire
c'est des cartes qui sont très efficaces
seulement aux situations précises par
exemple l'incitent à une quarantaine des
qui détruit un enchantement ou à
l'artefact peut-être ya plein de cas où
c'est pas bien et en veut pas quatre
mais si tu peux en avoir qu'une seule
équipe peut aller la chercher au monde
en a besoin c'est vachement bien avec
plus volatiles qui soit
qui s'adapte à plus de type de jeu voit
exactement j'ai pas voir par exemple six
cartes différentes qui font tout un truc
spécifique une qui va manger des
créatures une qui va manger des
artefacts qui va mal et enchantement
bein qui va faire gagner des points de
vie parce que si tu joues contre un mec
très agressif qui va descendre bas en pv
ça peut t'aider
voilà remontée site a par exemple une
305 points 10 bah ça va bien bloqué un
des cas gressier et du coup ça permet
d'avoir ce qu'on appelle une troupe box
donc une balade une boîte à outils avec
différentes créatures qu'on des effets
qui sont voilà très variés et c'est
typiquement le genre de mec comme moi
j'aime beaucoup jouer
donc voilà je trouve cette carte est
très sympa
si vous voulez voir marie amélie ouvrir
quelques booster voilà un aperçu de ce à
quoi ça ressemble à tap tap ou des
éditions différentes du coup c'est la
guerre des prix walker si on arrive à
avoir des cartes un peu rigoler devant
la gare des places walker c'est un c-17
cas spécifiques où tu es obligé d'avoir
au moins un plein sur le corps dans son
tombeau star ok donc du coup pouvoir le
voir on est d'accord que la rareté
sceller les petits le petit symbole
ouais au milieu à droite ceux qui sont
noirs donc les 10 premières avant être
commune parce que je descende du chat de
gouttière will est sympa le chien
patrick lang est responsable des réseaux
sociaux tu t'y connais en charge contre
la syrie une partie importante de mon
travail
regarder des vidéo chat atteint un autre
challenge à valence en plus à temps ces
thématiques
un 3e charles 3e charles fenain
ah oui disons oui il avait une tête
voilà
il ya peut être un plus haut le coeur
qui est pas mal du tout c'est un rare et
g et 1 to kane le taux kahn n'est pas
une carte qui compte normalement si je
me trompe pas les c'est un tocard qui
est gratuit dans tout les boosters en
plus ils disent 15/4 exactement les 15
plus une
qui donc vous avez vu tout à l'heure
quand on a mis nos petits dés et tout
est bon à force d'avoir des taux cannes
comme ça c'est plus sympa visuellement
c'est plus clair c'est ça et après tu
peux faire de tout comme toi-même par
exemple si tu veux tu es par exemple par
une copine qui aime bien dessiné bien la
fête et aucune plante les pokémon
qu'elle soit là quand elle joue avec des
peaux qualité totem planté poisson
bizarre son mystère mais je lui fais ce
petit plant je regardais si pour autant
j'avais une carte qui produisait le
zombie dans le booster magic a
l'impression en général les plaines sur
le coeur liliane a fondé tocane zombies
donc je sais pas si la ligne n a que
vous avez eue dans votre nom ne fait pas
tomber je crois il fait non il les sort
de créatures que vous lancez ce tour ci
peuvent pas être contrecarré est une
créature ciblé que vous contrôlez se bat
contre une créature ciblé que vous
contrôlez pas mais dont pas mal ça peut
forcer un adversaire a bloqué pas ce qui
est bien plus en plus il a un effet
pastiche qui fait que toutes les
créatures gagne plus en de force ah oui
et toutes les créatures en plus en plus
0 effectivement qu'au moment où tu le
poste est créé à dire du même plus fort
des yeux tu es tu peux manger une
créature adverse
ça te fait un bon ami de tempo qui est
assez fort et d'ailleurs voyons je
voulais te dire dans le booster que vous
avez eu par exemple qu'il y avait dans
votre quotidien d'ouvrir il y avait une
des cartes la carte rouge s'appelle
george orwell c'est attendait qu'elle
quitte les rouges
la roja de deux contrats oui c'est une
liste actuelle anomalie en bleu sa voix
pourrait pas les mots en français en
anglais en général ça c'est une de 2
pour 3 et 10 h pas toujours un sens non
créatures et gagna marqueur plus en plus
ça par exemple c'est typiquement le
genre de cartes qu'il irait bien dans le
lac de valentin thaler et qu'il avait
beaucoup sur mon crâne rouge
c'est un thème qui est très classique
dans les bleues rouges de manière
générale les trucs qui sont autour des
sorts et vos créatures définir jacques
les sens
voilà j'ai pas vu que l'addition c'est
elle qui sait c'est l'édition 2020 ouais
ça un mois avec un superbe vampire assez
saurine ce temps plein soit le quart a
vampire tout à fait c'était le dec noir
avec lequel on aurait pu jouer si
j'étais mort plus rapidement au tour
d'avant donc non résolus ces indicateurs
de rareté ses sucs et sur le symbole le
magic 20 ouais c'est toujours sur le
symbole puis dès que je veux juste dire
que sorry il est un peu un design the
witcher personnage le empire avec une
grande épée on sait pas trop quel âge il
a du coup suggéré mais aussi un claim
sous le coeur dedans oui ça pour le coup
c'était pas du tout obligatoire c'est
juste vous qu'avec du vol ces âges
animateurs de la bande c je me trompe
pas passer la journée lavande vraie
force de la borne moi je mets le sourire
à côté vous voyez le design ouais bah si
vous avez un dais blanc je pense qu'il
rentrera dans la majorité des plantes
sauvages annila il est plutôt sympa est
ce que tu peux nous dire nous parler du
si je me trompe pas du foil les cartes
qui sont un peu brillante
ouais c'est ça bah ça c'est il ya
certaines cartes dans les boosters vous
ai pas oubliés dans la voir mais ils ont
vu que les gens aimaient ça donc ils en
font plus en plus donc des cartes qui
brille moi je trouve ça joli donc les
biens et d'avoir des gens qui pour sa
page ollier du goût qui les aiment pas
ton général va venir de fanni
ouais c'était brillant qui est capable
justement valais les collectors et lé
bris en train les plus rares et elle est
brillante et ça leur donnait une valeur
que ça leur permettait de
à moindre coût qualifié quelque chose
d'autre parce que ils imprimaient des
photos s'étaient tous ces avis y avait
rien d'autre n'y avait pas de pas de
pouvoir il n'y avait pas de game design
associés c'était vraiment il avait
acheté les droits d'un dessin animé
utilisez les captures d'écran des fois
d'ailleurs en résolution pas terrible
voilà et c'est un business qui a
incroyablement bien marché soit ok bah
là par exemple je voudrais que walker
epa plaine dans le car mais la carte que
vous avez ouvert donc qui est donc en
anglais say and our itx est une carte
qui est très puissante et qui a été
bannie dans plusieurs formats si je me
trompe pas on prend les gafi et en
modernisant moderne mais du coup qui est
dark est très très fort qu ils ont
décidé au final qu'il ya des formats
dans laquelle on pourrait pas la jouer
parce que c'était trop puissant après
plutôt une ouverture sympa et c'est une
carte qui a ses contraintes huitième
dans la façon dont elle fonctionne en
gros si tu peux la lire tu verras que tu
vas pas forcément comprendre comment ça
marche non parce que je sais pas ce que
c'est l'échappée chèques cartes non
terrain dans votre cimetière à
l'échappée le coup d'échapper est égal
au coût de mana de la carte plus l'exil
de trois autres cartes de votre
cimetière
oui j'avais rejoint les fuit la brèche
l'échappée ça veut dire que tu peux
rejouer une carte depuis son cimetière
comme si l'état entame un mais du coup
je dois payer un coût supplémentaire
c'est-à-dire exilés des quarts de tons
cynthia fleury les bannières pour
toujours de la partie
oui l'idée c'est qu'en milieu de partie
à peu près quand à jouer des créatures
qu'elles sont mortes etc rabat a
beaucoup de cartes qui sont arrivés dans
ton si pierre qui font la haie qui font
plus grand chose et du coup là tu peux
t'en servir comme ressource pour jeter
carton et l'idée c'est qu'avec cette
carte là il y avait les dec combo qui
arrivait à remplir énormément leurs
cimetières du coup pouvait trouver une
carte qui pourra mana et mettait les
cinq gars du sud est dans le cimetière
et d'oscar qu'ils aient du mal à et du
coup battu finissait par mettre tout on
n'est qu'au cimetière et du coup avec la
la la brèche tu pouvais jouer la carte
que tu voulais et tu ton adversaire avec
sa pratique
c'était beaucoup trop beaucoup trop
régulier
du coup ils ont décidé que ça l'ait pas
exister dans un dd qu'on a qu'on a testé
en s'entraînant assez marrant c'est là
avec marie amélie avant elle avait une
carte qui était co bon intéressante
c'est si vous avez invoquer des
créatures pour cinq ou six coups
différents l'adversaire meurt mais
c'était pas dans un des textes et dans
un égout steurs a coûté assez rigolo ça
ok je vois je pense que ça devait être
mais ça c'est sympa
il ya pas mal de choses à dire dans ce
booster là ça c'est sympa on peut
commencer par le truc le plus évident
c'est que tu as une carte double donc
c'est incubation incongruité problement
fonctionne oui exactement
et du coup c'est une carte ou quand tu
l'a choisi quand tu la joues tu choisis
quel côté de la carte tu veux jouer en
fait ce qui du coup lui donne beaucoup
de flexibilité même si les deux effet
ils sont pas ou peu joué l'un ou l'autre
dans le cas présent la y en a un qui va
te chercher une créature parmi les cinq
heures de suite on deck et l'autre qui
peut gérer une créature la transformer
en 33 c'est plutôt un repli de 7,7
ouais t'as gros cochon ça ça coûte très
cher mais par contre quand tu le penses
tu gagnes en général il ya beaucoup de
textes sur la carte et expositions cela
dit c'est pour human and death est cette
vigilance célérité piétinement si je me
trompe pas et quand elles arrivent en
jeu et d'une plaie de blé de toutes les
créatures toutes les autres créatures en
jeu et la vigilance
il faut dire qu'ils mangent jusqu'à la
fin du tout ah oui avec sa radio 6 2
forte ça ça rajoute 6-2 fort tu peux
attaquer avec tout sans trop de risques
en général leur faveur du mal et il ya
une carte sur laquelle vous n'êtes pas
trop arrêté mais qui paradoxalement est
la carte la plupart de l'édition
probablement laquelle qui est là échappé
dans les friches un truc comme ça en
français
non ça c'est une autre voyageuse
réclamations celles qui quelle couleur
c'est l'enchantement vert à droite
français à droite le reboisement des
régions reculées
oui au début de votre rue boisement la
région au fil des terrains 8 6 c'est ça
et en gros c'était fait la médicaux tour
où tu va le jouer tu vas dégagé en fin
de tour toutes les terrains ce qui veut
dire que virtuellement int a rien coûté
si tu as de quoi utiliser ton manas par
le toronto l'adversaire et ensuite tous
les tours suivants à partir du jour où
tu la joues et il a doublé tombe en fait
à chaque tour je vais très vite arriver
à les contrer bien là agrimer c'est pas
mal exactement
eh ben actuellement il ya un tournoi qui
va se dérouler ce week-end est donc le
player tour final c'est en gros c'est
pas les championnats du monde mais c'est
le truc juste en dessous c'est une très
très grosse compétition à 150 joueurs
avec 250 mille dollars en cash price et
le dec le plus jouer ce sera le dec qui
joue sarah hanffou cadres et genre
quasiment tout le monde je faisais que
là parce que c'est beaucoup trop fort
quoi ok ok ben m'hidi piège des bonnes
cartes comme aimant sur balles et pas la
patronne dans dix ans d'ouverture de
mostar je sais que survivre quand
l'adversaire a plus de point de vue et
donc le dernier qui est
raven igga c'est qu'en plus je je en
tant que suisse s je suis un peu
gardienne de la montre et je vois qu'on
joue les prolongations pour la team est
réelle c'est pas jojo décote est-ce
qu'il faut que je continue à donner des
anecdotes ou pas du coin oui
vas-y vas-y dans le cas présent c'est un
truc sur rave nikara venus casser un
monde spécifique qu'ils ont un cahier d
inventer pour les sourds de magic et cas
tellement plus haut aux joueurs qui sont
revenus deux fois sur ce plan là qu'il y
aurait à venir car au début après un
retour sur veronica et la céramique à
ali james l'allégeance de radnic a du
coup la troisième fois qu'ils reviennent
sur l'avenir
donc au début c'était en 2005
je pense qu'ils ont dû faire 2005 2010
2015 en 2005 2008 2018 prolonge donc
c'est un monde qui est très sympa et qui
est beaucoup autour débit coloris tu es
[Musique]
et tu verras que ton terrain de base en
fait dans ton booster avenue guidance
est toujours remplacés par un terrain
qui fait de couleurs vert et blanc ici
en l'occurrence top
est ce que tu vois une carte qui
méritent ou ce qu'on libère nos
collègues way
il ya une carte qui est contre intuitive
et j'aime bien c'est la carte noire que
trop mignonne ton écran de tonton tapis
j'ai pas du tout le monde
ouais j'ai failli signer en français en
français chez font un point et là c'est
sympa si tu veux lire le texte
tu vois la façon dont elle fonctionne
assez contre intuitive et le frisson
rampant inflige trois blessures à chaque
adversaire et vous gagnez 3 points de
vie quand le frisson rampant et mis dans
votre cimetière depuis autres
bibliothèques vous pouvez l'exil et si
vous faites ainsi le frisson rang points
affiche trois blessures à chaque
adversaire et vous gagnez 3 points de
vue et on recense actuellement c'est à
dire que si tu arrives à défaut et c'est
depuis ton cimetière cette carte elle se
joue gratuitement et du coup à la rendre
dans des jeux un peu combo qui ont
intérêt à défaut c'est tout leur dec
oui et ça joue des cartes gratuitement
depuis leurs dagues et si tu arrives à
faire les 4 400 exemplaires maximum 2
chez carte par dec exactement ça fait
douze points gratuits enfin ce week end
privé dans la sphère donc si tu fait si
tu fais la course était vraiment ok ok
bah on espère que ce premier live sur
magic vous a plu vous a donné envie de
jouer au jeu surtout nous pour
l'anecdote depuis qu'on a depuis qu'on a
décidé de faire ce live on a on s'est
remis à jouer un petit peu avec marie
amélie et chaque fois qu'on jouait dans
au sahel dans un couloir ou autres
nombre de collègues s'arrêtait et nous a
dit je jouais à une époque où autres
donc et plusieurs se sont s'ils sont
remis
je reste sur un ratio de victoires
défaites aussi aussi naze de toute façon
mais ça reste plaisant mais entraîne toi
tu verras ça ça viendra tout en traînant
secret sans lui dire et après d'âpres et
y revient à moi je sais que
personnellement oui je sais que moi
personnellement je travaille dans
l'informatique et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui jouent ou ont joué
en belgique
parmi les informaticiens donc si vous
êtes en rapport avec le service
informatique il ya probablement des gens
qui auraient dit que là-bas ça ne
m'étonnerait pas en tout cas merci à
toutes et à tous ainsi au chat
merci aux équipes merci à charles darwin
qui nous dit tout fort guette premier
rôle dans fargo
simon donc le cm et qui dit y avait
encore des questions sur premier roule
donc en répondre
reprise de premiers rôles à la rentrée
j'ai pas encore les dates on va repartir
pour quelques épisodes sur l'avant-bras
turin s'il parle de la campagne
principale que que vous suiviez si vous
restez abonnés soit à l'instar g deux
premiers rôles c'est la manière la plus
simple d'être houleux à jeter
actionnaires mais le hashtag sur twitter
hashtag premiers rôles vous inquiétez
pas on vous mettra la date précise
l'idée étant début septembre de repartir
voilà et fibre nous a dit qu'il avait un
deck blanc qui prenait la poussière
depuis des années donc qui sait ça
m'étonnerait pas de lui ce qui j'ai
gratté un problème 1 j'ai écouté un peu
premiers rôles et je me disais que s'il
avait bien le projet du genre de matches
et de profil du joueur
je pense que leurs profits les joueurs
et de tous je pense qu'il est beaucoup
trop virilo de diabolo le diabolo il
joue il joue à tous je suis sûr qu'ils
jouent à tous
en tout cas merci beaucoup beaucoup à
tous merci d'avoir réussi à faire en
sorte que l'on puisse faire une émission
magic au figaro c'est plutôt cool quand
même merci beaucoup beaucoup charles à
la fois pour ton temps tu as patience ta
bienveillance
mais avec les heures écoutait merci au
chat donc pensé aussi pardon je
reviendrai à penser à les suivre
le podcast de charles qui s'appelle
redonne mois le nombre cerveau me des
greens par les oreilles appelle le
podcast hermach fait casterman le pen
car taper sur google c'est tout ça va se
trouver exactement
merci justement avec une quinte voilà
merci beaucoup julien pour la réelle
merci simon proulx cm et puis bat kevin
pour les ja biarritz magnifique
d'habillage
je vais regarder leurs plaies presque
juste pour ça et le plaisir du moment où
je croyais mourir mais finalement non
merci alors que m'avoir laissé cette
chance
c'était pour le chat evans et mariam n
est pas très bientôt sur figaro live
pour les prochains direct à l'est
[Musique]